by 2050 several countries could
disappear underwater why because of
rising sea levels the most at risk is
Keira bass it's an island nation halfway
between Australia and Hawaii roughly the
size of the United States but only 2% of
it is land and that land is just 3
meters above sea level
some of Carabas islands are already
underwater and half of its population
has fled to the tiny capital of South
Tarawa which now has one of the highest
population densities in the world
the government has begun a program to
train citizens and skills like nursing
or mechanics that would make them
attractive migrants to other countries
and it's even bought a large chunk of
land in neighboring Fiji which says it's
willing to host kara bases population so
will the rest of the world start paying
attention before the people of Carabas
become the first wave of refugees
fleeing from the rising sea people in
Carrie bus as it's known here live just
beyond the Dateline every day they're
among the first to see the Sun Rise